[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super excited to be talking about
collective intelligence for the public
we're gonna be talking about sociology
you'll be talking about data science and
collective learning excited to have dr.
Nick Adams joining us on the show hi
Alan good to see you good to see you
thank you so much for coming on so I did
shout out to Melanie Mathieu for
introducing us we love you so much
Thank You Melanie yes prelate biologics
and for those that don't know Nick's
background he is a sociologist
he's data scientist he's a multi company
founder he did his PhD at Berkeley in
sociology and we're gonna be diving into
a great amount of depth here I'm super
excited let's start things off with this
big history perspective on civilization
sure we find ourselves as stewards of
Earth after a long period of evolution
and here we are seven point eight
billion of us with exponential
technology what is your current
synthesis on the state of humanity the
state of humanity well I think we're at
an interesting inflection point what I
see coming down the pike is that we
really need to figure out as a species
if we're mostly going to be running
ourselves according to kind of this
elite robot consensus or if we're going
to figure out how to distribute our
governance and our decision-making in
our cooperation in a way that's orderly
and allows us to kind of all come up
together whoa that was so interesting
okay so whoa
okay elite robot governance versus kind
of raising the baseline for everyone and
with more maybe like a heart centric
mentality so teach us about what you
what you mean by those two options cuz
that's yeah I mean so there was Davos
just
couple weeks ago yeah the World Economic
Forum's annual conference and in the
discussion was a lot was about you know
can billionaires avoid taxes but it was
I read an article where someone was
talking about the mood and the sense
that maybe even the elite didn't have
answers to the various questions they're
plaguing societies at the macro level so
brexit and Trump and the turn to the
right in some other countries in Europe
in a populist version of the right might
actually be indicators that they don't
have their hands on everything anyway
that they have for the last several
decades we also have this rising
influence of automation and artificial
intelligence and robots that's just kind
of on the horizon coming down the pike
or in the next 10 years or so where
we're concerned about people losing jobs
and so forth but there's also an
opportunity there for for perhaps the
elite to kind of automate a bunch of the
economy and people themselves become
even less consequential in the economy
therein it can be discarded yes
economically and in terms of our
governments and that's a big concern
that's a big concern to me as someone
who you know I guess along the way I've
been fully indoctrinated and
capital D democracy like I do think it's
safer and better for humans to
distribute our decision-making and find
ways to include people so with education
an educated democracy yes so crucial
yeah the public needs to know as much as
it can about the decisions that affect
its individual members and they need to
have enough time to be able to explore
what to do how the democracy is moving
itself in the directions the options
when people are working so 16 hours they
sleep for 8 and they don't have time to
read or learn anything outside of that
16 hour then ya can't be informed I
think in many ways democracy is a really
great idea that's yet to be tried or at
least certainly yet to be fully tried
and when I see when I see Facebook with
2 billion users whatever people say
about how well they're doing and with
particular aspects of their business
model or whatever you to come to billion
as well yeah what I see are is
incredible in potential to to guide and
shape the behavior of other humans for
good or for bad but shouldn't we be
trying to steer it towards the good out
of every four people yeah yeah but you
can compare the capacity for behavioral
change that we have in software to what
we've had historically
used to take decades or centuries to
change people's the way people behave on
a regular basis through religion through
warfare and conflict and politics but
Facebook has come along in 15 years and
fundamentally reshaped the behavior of 2
billion people so there's we have an
incredible capacity we have not even
quite figured out how to use it yet and
we haven't even really tried yet to to
use it for democratic purposes yeah mmm
it's nuts to think about how it used to
take hundreds of years and books of
religion to influence two billion people
aiming to disseminate it across the
printing press and and and one-on-one
conversations and now there were
algorithms and the internet you can cast
in 15 years two billion human primates
can now be influenced with these
algorithms that's so crazy yeah and I
I'm very interested in your you know
your sociology I on this and your data
science I on this because you us moving
into you know this is an inflection
point that we have a lot of wealth now
concentrated in a small amount of people
more than ever before and that there's
got to be some increase in heart centric
thinking and increasing the baseline for
the rest unleashing the creativity that
can unfold from them the maximizing of
their own potential that can unfold from
them which is super exciting thinking
about what they can create and make as
long as their basic needs are met and
they have access to these tools so how
do you best see us making that
flourishing happen
I'm really glad I've heard you say no
this this phrase heart centric a couple
times and it's not it's not something
that not a term I use a ton but I very
much resonate with it and I can I can
talk about it from my own experience as
you said I've founded quite a few
different organizations
and part of the reason for that is that
I've most the time that I'm in an
organization I have the experience you
know some organization I didn't found
I've had the experience that the impulse
towards hierarchy whether it's flows of
information or power or steam or
whatever are very strong and that it's
actually counterproductive to creativity
so I don't know that I've even been
totally aware that that's the main
problem that's causing me to start these
other organizations but every time I
start an organization we end up
collaborating in ways where I think
we're all kind of surprised that it
works so easily and so well and the the
key to it all is to not behave with that
spirit of hierarchy and to create open
space for people's own creative impulses
so I think it's it's a little bit of a
shame that here we are in the 21st
century you know over a million years
into our evolution and we actually don't
have you know a recipe book for there's
how to create here's how to run good
meetings here's how to create an
organization that really promotes
creativity and this open thinking so
that's something that we are kind of
working on and we're kind of a little
embarrassed that we don't know more
about it but so far so good in terms of
the spirit and and if we can make that a
set of institutions or practices that
can be replicated
we'll feel like we've accomplished quite
a bit you again this is like there's
where is the basic code how do we not
have a basic code for birthing a human
into the world and having them learn
about their heart centric thinking
maximizing their potential the limited
time they have the hundred billion
humans that came before them to build
civilization yeah these basic things
where we came from who we are where
we're going that we're so lacking that
would actually that collective
intelligence would then help us so much
you've pointed at this a couple times
now this kind of like democracy 2.0 this
capitalism 2.0 this inclusive global
thinking perspective that the transition
to that is coming and it's up to us to
help inspire more people to think that
way and to and to flourish that way so I
want to ask you about that transition
what do you think to get to democracy
2.0 capitalism 2.0 social networking
knowledge graphing 2.0 how do we make
that transition through projects like
yours of course yeah we're really
committed to so kind of living in the
future we're building what we want the
future to look like and we just we kind
of lived there goodly labs and and
that's linked with tag works those
organizations we're not interested in
kind of fighting or resisting current
situations or scenarios or organizations
of power or resources or anything if if
we can build the future that people want
to live in and expand from there
yeah then
you know there's we don't need a bloody
revolution or anything we just need to
be able to give people the tools they
need to collaborate and work together I
like that a lot
yeah so you you make the option
available and then you gravitate people
towards that option towards this tool
set and you've you've also identified
this in your previous statement about
creativity being quelled unfortunately
in many regards by Ron and I talk about
this so much but that when people are
like two jobs three jobs go and work and
work and work
there's no time to actually reflect on
your life and reflect on what you're
learning in other humans and economies
and governments and civilization
evolving to get here and when you have
the time to reflect creatively you would
explain there's a hierarchy well when
you're working at Facebook let's say and
you're being told by the top this is
what your engineering this is what
you're designing this is what you're
building with your operations teams that
there is little room for you every day
to creatively pursue what new ideas you
have to actually make these platforms
these companies that we work at better a
more of a header are kacal structure
around creativity would actually be
interesting to pursue and find okay
let's yeah I mean it's it's I was saying
it's kind of shocking we don't know how
to do this stuff we also don't have
really great indisputable research on
human motivation on like what actually
motivates people to be creative and to
produce there's kind of an assumption a
theory that we need to keep them in a
state of precarity where you know they
might get kicked out in the street
unless they do work work of a certain
kind for an organization that's you know
telling them exactly
do something for the bottom line of that
organization yeah I think we should be
thoroughly questioning that and it's
it's not a surprise if you look at the
intellectual history of the Social
Sciences they they were they all began
as handmaidens to the state and states
that were usually autocracies at the
time they were building the first
universities and starting to build these
disciplines and their primary interest
was in making a population that was more
productive more docile more easy to
manage obedient workers so yeah I don't
know that that anyone with a great deal
of resources has ever really pursued
trying to allow people to be creatively
productive in their own ways yeah yeah
and that's where we're that's where we
need to head it is enabling the
flourishing that baseline moving up and
and the creative flourishing I think so
I think we should have more faith in our
fellow humans I agree if we give them
those capacities they're you know they
might fart around a little bit but
they're for the most part they're gonna
do good things with that capacity I
agree absolutely dude it's like you
can't the mind has so much creative
potential just the once the basic needs
are met and the tools are given the
capacities unlimited where those
imaginations can go and build all right
let's talk your trajectory so you found
your you found yourself super interested
in sociology and data science enough to
go get a PhD enough to to start public
editor and to start tag works and to be
exploring these collective learning
solutions so teach us about that
trajectory we've got the fire under your
buzzer yeah I guess that's all kind of
collective intelligence
ride started for me back when I was
working on my dissertation and I wanted
to understand interactions between
police and protesters and city
governments across every Occupy movement
and there were there 184 of them going
on in the US during 2011 my advisors
were like you should just compare four
cities and that's a good dissertation
but I really wanted to have data on all
of them all 184 because that gives a lot
more comparative leverage to go deep and
understand that you know how various
sequences of interaction might lead to
violence or a negotiation or anything in
between the more data you have the more
comparative leverage you have to tease
out some of those dynamics and so with
you know with a lot of naivete I jumped
into the project and collected nearly
10,000 news articles describing
everything going on and then I pretty
quickly realized that the there weren't
really tools available to analyze all of
those documents in close detail and the
way that I wanted to but I just kind of
puzzled on that for a while and I you
know a lot of time at the at the drawing
board and trying things out with my team
of research assistants and actually kind
of came upon the design that's now
attack
which is a the key to the design is that
you take the very complex job of
applying like all of these different
labels to your tons and tons of
documents it's a very complicated task
but you can break it out into an
assembly line of small simple tasks and
then stitch all of that together at the
end so that you might have a two page
document that's reviewed by 40 different
people but and at the end you have you
have labels all over the document
picking out all the data that would be
important in your analysis and it's as
good as any expert but you didn't have
to train them you don't have to
supervise them all of that happens in
the software itself so it's it's a it's
basically adding a new capacity to
social science whereas before we can
never really dig into these archives at
any kind of scale we now we can take on
an archive of any size and develop a
really intricate knowledge graph of
what's going on in that document archive
I love how your projects are birthed out
of the necessities in your dissertation
and which a lot of the times yeah that
is the mother of innovation is necessity
and so this theme is actually frequently
reoccurring for people around the world
is that they have this usually some sort
of a corpus of knowledge but then they
don't know how to how to parse query
that corpus of knowledge and catalog
things by tags and search by tags this
is a frequent problem that we have and
it's interesting that you when I'm happy
that you went on and did 184 right
instead of just four that's very
interesting and then with being able to
parse 10,000 of these pieces of
documentation to be able to to take and
find these keys from it it's like you go
and you accrue such a massive corpus but
then can you easily automate finding the
keys right from it and imagine how much
more knowledge we could be getting and
so
this is very interesting so keep telling
us about it well we're really excited
about the possibility of being able to
take knowledge corpora yeah we let me
start this answer again we're not live
all right yeah ported corpora
yeah corpora which is just the plural of
corpus and it's one of these
yeah these self mystifying lingo things
out of the Academy but a set of
documents right so you can there is
there are sets of documents that kind of
describe all of Medicine there are sets
of documents that describe our legal
system and how it functions and you know
people go to school for a while to
become to develop sufficient expertise
that they can then like share that when
they want to for a price to other people
and this kind of professionalization of
knowledge actually it kind of ensures
that there are different classes in
relation to that knowledge there are
people who who have it and people who
don't and if you don't then you you pay
a pretty penny this hierarchy of the
knowledge graph and then the valves are
sometimes closed from the top to not you
want to flow you want the data to flow
yeah and over time what this has done is
it's it's like prevented humans from
being more well-rounded from
understanding ourselves and how we can
relate to each other or even something
as simple as nutrition like it's it's
kind of wild to me that we're in the
21st century and we don't we don't know
what we should be eating and there's
like so much conflicting information
that you can see this across the
different knowledge sectors that are
professionalized and that's something
that
we expect to be very different in 20 or
30 years because of the work we're doing
now this process of making collective
learning more effective is one of the
most important things that we could be
doing right now we were talking earlier
about using technology for good and
enabling more people to have this this
access to this collective learning to
help them that doing things in that
realm are some of the most important
things we can be doing so I love how
you're focused on this ok so how did the
inspiration come then for a public
editor as well because this mass
collaboration software for the news is
very interesting there's yep especially
because there's a lot of things at play
here there's people's biases to write
certain news in the direction of their
favor rather than just an objectively
neutral state on the news there is
writing it that way because then they
can get clicks because then they can get
ad dollars right so I mean we're really
excited about public editor this is a
collective intelligence system that the
public can use to to collaborate to join
together and analyze news articles and
put labels all over the articles that
pick out the words and phrases that
might commit some argumentative fallacy
or show some psychological bias or be
some you know inferential mistake or
something like that and all of these
labels that were applying are are based
on actually centuries of of science
scientific method that humans have
developed so we are as a species with
science in particular we've figured out
the ways that we fool ourselves and we
figured out how to avoid those mistakes
all of that has been kind of captured in
a curriculum that's taught by Saul
Perlmutter at UC Berkeley Saul
Perlmutter he won the Nobel Prize for
inventing all right for discovering the
universe
expanding at an increasing rate he knows
something about science and he's a very
popular and enthusiastic lecturer who's
got hundreds of students taking this
course on scientific style critical
thinking loved it so he came to me three
years ago and said hey I see that you've
got this tag works tool could that be
used to find examples of misinformation
in the news because I had this class
where we learned all these different
thinking mistakes humans make we'd like
to point them out in news articles
that's really the genesis of the public
editor project and so we kind of like we
kind of sketched out some designs and it
was kind of a backburner project until
2016 when there became all this concern
about about fake news spreading and we
kind of moved it to the front burner and
we've been we've been really working at
it for the last couple of years and then
we now have a you know what could be
described as humanity's first
collaborative [ __ ] detector you
ready to do the first collaborative
[ __ ] detector that's so great
you know what am I gonna do okay
speaking of that really quick this this
humanities collaborative [ __ ]
detector come enjoy enjoy this okay
there's so much BS in the world we
pursue bigger cars bigger houses and
bigger salaries that we become so
materialized we can barely stand honesty
vulnerability and spirituality that all
changes around death taalib wild hmm yep
so I just I wanted to bring that forth
because the BS in this world yeah it
melts away around death when you're
dying you're remembering just the most
profound parts of your life like did I
pass enough time with my friends and my
family did I execute on the jury
that I wanted to bring forth into the
world and so when we see all this BS
when were twenty and thirty and forty
and fifty around the time of the
clickbait tea advertising economy
attention economics side of things that
to find the objective neutral stances on
these perspectives and getting fed just
what is the most objective and neutral
state so that you can parse and
understand what is actually happening is
so critical and so you know we we were
as you were as you were talking we were
showing some of the the public editor
sides of things and and this is again to
be able to assess this this news cycle
which is so people I know are writing
scientists I know are writing what are
some of the profound synthesis of their
fields into like medium posts or into
articles for certain journals and
whatnot
and then people stop looking at it after
two or three days yeah and it's gone and
it's on to the next thing
yeah but these are some of the best
synthesis so they're dying in the click
Beatty 24-hour news cycles so so so
public editor is a good tool here for
the collective learning yeah and I and I
think our I was at a great conference
this past weekend and someone who was
talking about the degradation of reading
and they they were able to look at the
way people read and they can follow
their eye tracking on a screen and
they've been able to look at this over
time and look at it in different cohorts
different generations interesting and
see that people are reading much less
attentively yeah than we used to and I
think it's in some ways a response to
the increasing amount of noise
yes in our discourse and our dialogue I
found myself now I read you know they
call it reading in the shape of a Z yep
instead of going straight down line by
line and I've I found myself actually
beginning to do this over the last
couple years because I know that the
point of an article is to is to be
clickbait and I want to read the
headline and then get through a little
bit to make sure that the article
actually is consistent with the headline
but when we're all doing this it means
the the capacity of our discourse to
affect change into and for people to
take it seriously is diminished across
the board including these syntheses it's
important pieces that are getting lost
yet I love how you you know you're
talking about finding the keys in our
collective learning and having tools
like tag works which enable us to more
effectively find the keys or in the
collective learning and that's basically
what we do when we jump into something
where we want to look in a Z and we're
trying to get through it because we're
trying to find the best keys of
knowledge in the shortest amount of time
that's kind of what we're doing with
this information foraging okay so with
so with with public editor we can jump
on to the platform and we can we can
collaborate with other people on being
able to look at different pieces of news
right so there are two different ways to
to like be involved with public editor
of the simplest lowest weight way is to
just be a reader and you can we'll have
a browser extension out soon where you
can get an overlay on any article that
will show one of these credibility
hallmarks with a with a zero to ninety
nine credibility score you know and then
all the labels on the document all the
labels on the news article so you can go
to the New York Times and if it's gone
through our system it'll just show up
that way and tell us about the system's
a little yeah so and then and then
another way to interact with public
editor is to actually be a volunteer and
be a contributor yeah and and then what
happens is you'll be you'd be given
various different tasks where you're
doing some thin
assessment of the article or just some
small piece of the article so maybe
you're reading through and you're
finding passages where there's evidence
used to support some claim and that's it
you're just finding passages where
evidence is used to interest and then
it's someone else's job they'll be asked
a series of questions that look a lot
like a reading comprehension quiz yep
and as they answer the questions they
also highlight the text that justifies
their answer cool and that's what's
labeling the document with these
different assessments of like oh well
yeah I guess I see some exaggeration in
the tone here and then there's a
follow-up question that's like well how
severe is it and if it's very severe
then we're gonna take off two or three
points for that if it's very mild we
might take off one or zero points were
right interesting the exaggeration of
claims
yeah I'm copies are like comprehensive
reading tests that people take about the
article right interesting so you're also
breeding a new era of critical thinkers
yeah critical thinking media literacy
you can get it passively just by reading
the news with public editor overlaid but
if you're a contributor and the system
you're going to learn a lot about what
constitutes quality information when we
don't know things and how to read and
write within those parameters and if
more and more people start going and
landing on the pages with the plug-in
and seeing scores of forty thirty these
low scores and they start telling their
friends hey look I've been I've been
I've been parsing the these different
websites for their media literacy scores
as I myself have been critically
thinking and seeing how they're actually
grading these platforms and I'm finding
the ones that score eighty or ninety to
be way more effective for for my
knowledge and my critical thinking than
the ones that are completely biased that
are trying to cause echo chambers that
are trying to cause cognitive bias and
E's and exactly there's also there's an
issue that that people are really
concerned about and we probably all
experienced it
ourselves and what the people around us
called the backfire effect where once
there's a false idea in your head it's
very difficult for someone to convince
you to change that idea if it is if it
fits with the rest of your kind of
belief system so like false ideas
basically they kind of they take root
into your belief system and kind of then
they kind of hold on and no one's been
able to find particularly great ways to
solve that problem once it's taken root
but with public editor as you're reading
through the news if something is is
really biased or if it's posing a false
dilemma or if it's you know a straw man
fallacy or something like that you're
going to see that as you're reading it
and so it's it's you will always be
doubtful of that particular fact and it
won't take root in the first place so we
think we've found a way to interrupt one
of the thorniest problems with
misinformation yep you know this is the
future of media this is the future of
journalism this is the future of
critical thinking yeah of multi
disciplinary knowledge multivariate
analysis yeah we we hope so the and the
future of kind of social epistemology or
like knowing how do we know yeah
together and and know that we have the
same boundaries on what counts as truth
yes and they're using the same sort of
criteria to judge truth that's something
that a lot of people are in fear about
right now based on the data we have it's
certain that we have these ideological
tribes there's no doubt about that
there's a concern that we have
epistemological tribes where we can't
even hope to see things the same way and
I I have hope I do not I don't think
we're there yet
but it's something we can test with a
public editor system and it's something
where we can bring people together
across the political spectrum
with this or system we're gonna get
there we're gonna get there Ronnie well
the hope that you have there doc would
if you know they come at a Kia and they
come you know the faith that you have
they get it what if they're gonna kill
you
oh yeah well I I have worried about that
you should jog feelin among us
everything that we're talking about
there's a dark villain among us that
does not want us even discussing these
things making a better human boy you
know is that we need I mean when I worry
about that I am really afraid of that I
look at the team page the goodly loves
website and there's you know there's 70
or 80 people from across the generations
across the political spectrum across
like ethnicity gender everything who are
all working on this and the the ideas
for this and the even the operational
plans going forward are in their minds
so I think if someone comes after me I
mean I hate to imperil anyone on my team
but they would need to come after all of
us I guess we got an alert I don't like
by paper honey just in case that's a
great answer is that if you can take the
truce and and inspire enough people to
pursue the truth with a great deal of of
health and an intensity then then you
you can't you can't go and destroy the
truth when it's populated in hundreds
and thousands of people around the world
that are pursuing it at the same time
it's much more difficult to make a
strike on that so that actually is a big
point for when you are at the edge of
knowledge to push for at least someone
to help you disseminate that edge to
more people so that way it doesn't get
trapped in in one mind and lost in one
mind right actually okay so that's a lot
on public editor okay so now let's talk
more on on tag works which you already
started us on earlier but yeah so so
being able to to to analyze these large
amounts
documentation information and taking
these keys from it how does one use
let's get a little technical how does
one parse the natural language and then
find the keys yep
okay yeah so this this challenge of
natural language processing our parsing
natural language as you said is really
just you know it's a challenge of how do
we understand human language and if we
think about it in our in our own
interactions whether we're writing
emails or talking with someone there's
plenty of opportunity for ambiguity and
vagueness and difficulty understanding
each other a lot of our conversations
are what did you say what did you mean
and we're like even in our own native
languages so computers are even much
worse than humans generally dealing with
natural language and they're most of the
advancements in natural language
processing which is just a term for
computers trying to understand language
most of the advances in that have come
from humans labeling documents and then
training a computer to do what the
humans did so it's a it's a mission
supervised machine learning process but
you know like part of speech tagging
named entity resolution all this sort of
stuff is humans going through by hand
labeling stuff and then saying hey
computer try to do what the humans do
so we're we're at a we're at a place
right now where there's like there's
tons of buzz about AI and there's just
kind of a supposition that if we feed
computers a huge set of documents it'll
know what to do and that's just anyone
who has that I didn't used to used to
give up that idea it's not really gonna
work out that way and the problem with
you know until we had something like tag
works the problem is that all of the
tools for going through and labeling
documents were really designed for the
situation of a neck
BIRT reading through and there they know
all the different labels the different
highlighter pins right the different
colors of highlighter that they would
want to use and they can just read
through and kind of do it by themselves
or they can train a few people to think
about it the way they think about it and
maybe they can train a dozen people and
if they're if they're pretty good at
managing that of that sort of approach
just doesn't scale to these very large
sets of documents so that's what time
works is really built to do it's
designed so that as a researcher I can
have my expertise I can get it down on
paper hand it to a customer success
person that tag works and they take that
and they put it into an interface where
it's not the interfaces are not designed
so that one expert knows it all and tags
at all they're designed and broken down
to be very simple tasks that people on
the internet can do so that you can have
like a thousand or you know potentially
even 10,000 people at a time working on
your project
yeah and that's never that's never been
possible so that's yeah that's a that's
the gist of it damn that sounds so
exciting to be able to take these large
amounts of documentation and have human
help on a large scale of parsing it and
providing us with the proper tool stuff
to get to catalog this data to
effectively tag this data to make it
easier to query yes afterward and take
the knowledge from it right yeah when
everything is tagged this way you can
you know to the extent that your set of
documents is describing human behavior
you have this great data set of human
behavior and much of the most kind of
interesting and potentially explanatory
theory in social science is this kind of
you know not macro economical stuff and
not like little like psychological
experiments but this kind of mezzo level
theory that describes the way we
interact in groups so symbolic
interaction conversational analysis and
like dramaturgical theories that imagine
situations as like these kind of little
scripted plays that we that we go
through so like we all know the script
for getting a coffee we all know the
basic script for doing a date or giving
a talk or whatever like and we're just
going through our life with these
different scripts if you can actually
compare across those scripts and
situations you can start to see how the
many many features of the social world
are impinging on in the individuals
behavior in a given moment but you have
to have lots of data to be able to get
comparative leverage across so many
different variables that are affecting
human behavior and yes that lots of data
is often found in archives that are
describing events that's just like
that's one thing for for tag works you
can you can imagine I think your own go
ahead you can imagine looking at how
gender is expressed differently at
different times in places about how
ethnic categories are constructed and
how they change over time all of this
sort of stuff there's evidence of it in
the archives of the world and we can now
explore that even just saying the words
the archives of the world is so
interesting because what data have we
extracted from those archives of the
world and made applicable to collective
learning yeah it's so important to take
those keys and pass down this wisdom
that's what the hundred billion people
that lived before us that built
civilization they want us to be grateful
for everything they made they want us to
be grateful and understanding of these
wisdoms that they built civilization on
top of the arc
you're absolutely right the archivists
dream
I was giving a talk at the Library of
Congress about a year ago and the
archivists dream is that everyone's
using their archive like that that's the
raison d'être right and and that's
unfortunately not really what's
happening a lot the way that those
archives are kind of constructed in the
way they're organized even digitally
even in situations where you know
there's like we have a public archive of
what's going on in Congress we have a
public archive of what's happening in
the Supreme Court that stuff is actually
still only viewable kind of one text
file at a time and it's very much like
the same procedure and you would you
would undergo if you went to the
physical archive and you have to like
check out one document at time you have
to put on these like white gloves and
view it behind a pane of glass it's very
similar to the experience online where
if I want to know what my Congress
member is saying I have to like click on
this thing it's like opening a drawer
and find the right Congress and then
pull out a folder and then here's like
the different committees I have to click
on something there and then I have to
find the particular piece of paper and I
can't like take notes on it or annotate
on it or scribble on it I just have to
read through and take notes in a
separate document so there's a you know
a project at Goodley labs called
liberating the archives where we take
those archives and now what you can do
now what you can do thanks deliberating
archives if you want to understand what
your Congressman is up to you can go to
a website and you can say well I want to
I want to every single utterance
like anytime they open their mouth on
the record I want to be able to search
for that I can search for it by party by
gender by their name of course and you
know urban or rural so you can start to
see how the politics of the nation plays
out based on these variables in a way
that was you know it would have taken
you hundreds of hours to do
before I love it all these different
ways to to tap into this collective
learning archive and be able to extract
meaningful data from it that's what the
essence of a lot of what you're working
on is and yeah we're very grateful for
you building up this collective learning
for the public and we're very good and
we hope to have more people joining
public editor and tag work so guys those
links are below go and join in to to the
movement of collective learning for the
public this is huge
this is huge okay couple things on the
way out that we want to I want to talk
about so there's a really min your eyes
yeah yeah yeah we are we are now seeing
more and more of a push for this
collective learning to be expanded we
want to push the edge of knowledge
further in all the different directions
one can say that a thousand years ago
the edges of knowledge were more
contracted we didn't have as much of the
scientific method to go and pursue these
different okay so now the question is
our question to you is how can we most
effectively get children from birth out
to these different edges of knowledge
what do you think interesting that to
the edge I think you know what we're
trying to do with these tools is to
bring to bring some of the knowledge
closer to people yes to make it more
accessible so with the public editor
project people are getting an
opportunity to kind of interact with the
data and and build their own capacity to
discern between you know what's true and
what's not so we think those sorts of
skills are really important to build
absolutely on you can take another goal
a lattice project called the demo watch
project and that's that's the kind of
the continuation of the research on
occupy
and there we have people curating all
these news articles about what's going
on with the Occupy movement but we you
know we don't just have people do this
stuff like and at their computer
separate from an understanding of what
the whole project is about we we narrate
to everyone in our community like how
their effort curating this data
annotating this data is going to allow
us to then do these analyses that
discover how things go towards violence
so we can actually prevent it yes so
with all of the with all of our work we
want to with their good league lives we
want to be able to show people how their
effort ends up contributing to knowledge
that's really important to us like
knowledge it could be the difference
between us like sliding into a police
state or having you know healthy civic
strife from time to time in order to
work out yeah conflicts that gives us a
lot of meaning to is that contributed
effort to the collective learning if we
are using these platforms rather than
just consuming we can contribute most
really effectively with our time yeah
and with tag Rickson in general there
are people who they're they're gonna be
doing some of the slice of the discovery
of a knowledge graph but they can also
move up the chain there's actually kind
of a career ladder in mind where you you
start as someone who's working on a
project but then you can be someone
who's helping to lead these projects
because anyone with like a pretty clear
idea of what they're looking for in a
set of documents can lead a one of these
collective intelligence projects and we
really want to see a world where you
know there's actually like thousands of
little cottage businesses or people are
leading others in the discovery of these
various branches of these knowledge
graphs especially those that have
traditionally kind of
kept out of people's hands yes and is
there a way for them to potentially get
compensated as well oh absolutely well
lift with tag works a lot of the people
who contribute will probably be working
through Mechanical Turk or one of these
online marketplaces where they can earn
money but then they if they develop a
skillset around that they can they can
start what might be a very lucrative
small business you know you can take an
example of someone has an expertise they
have legal expertise related to like
ediscovery so they know how to look
through emails from a company and find
what's necessary for some legal case
this is this is like a skill set that
not every attorney has it having that
skill set doesn't make you an attorney
but you could build a business around
that that's actually incredibly
lucrative and you'd be managing a bunch
of people through the internet and
through the tag works interface as a
company we end up getting some slice of
that but a lot of the money is going to
that it's that small business owner so
anywhere there's there's expertise that
can be kind of liberated there's also
there's a there's a small business
opportunity for somebody and it's funny
for me to be saying these words because
I I never grew up like thinking I'd be
an entrepreneur or a business person I'm
a champion of that but I to the extent
that this is democratizing knowledge I'm
pretty excited about people being able
to to get in and
their little piece of it likewise yeah
okay
in the quick power three on the way out
what's a core driving principle of your
life so sorry it's really easy for me
because it's like I think about it all
the time it's really to leave the world
better than it wasn't like I loved it
yeah how about are we in a simulation
are we in Assen you were talking about
these scripts earlier and I loved it
when you were yapping about the script
because that is what it is you know the
code for going to use the bathroom you
know the code for ordering the coffee
you know the railroad for how you should
behave with another primate so you don't
whack them over the head in your social
settings so these scripts are very
interesting your heart beats a hundred
thousand times a day it's a script the
earth orbits every 365.25 days it's a
script right so yeah tell us about
simulation I mean this is a little bit
of a meta physicist as a hobby so I
thought about this before and I do I
would say that there's no clear evidence
that we aren't in a simulation so I
think it's it's a theory that's
consistent with the reality we
experience whether that simulation is
like programmed in a computer kind of
context I'm les
you know I don't have any strong
commitment about that but I you know you
can also imagine that we're all just
this fractured imagination of some deity
and like this stuff is really a mad like
at its core it's deity she's obviously
mentally disturbed whatever it is if
that's the case of who we are he's not
to be [ __ ] in his hand or it's an or
whatever it is I just want to say that
because otherwise there'd be a lot more
peace and flourishing if they weren't
for this it does cause you to have to
explain yeah you're right yeah yeah yeah
but yeah you know I think it's I think
it's plausible yeah interesting when we
were very in love with all different
aspects of what's how simulations are
actually very meaningful for for our
understandings because the a
civilization evolving
is is you can say in all these different
scripts that evolved with the Simula the
civilization evolving one can reimagine
what tweaking these variables would be
as the Simeon as the civilization
evolves and that can give lots of
collective wisdom to how we would want
to augment the existing civilization I
think that's an important addition
because the the notion of simulation can
lead people I mean given that it's like
unfalsifiable it could lead people to
think like that they're kind of
powerless but we see a lot of evidence
that we are constructing our society as
we go yeah so I you know part of what's
attractive to me about this like you
know fractured consciousness of the
universe that is agentic is that we have
the capacity to create our reality and
recreate it and make it better than it
is so yeah I especially like the theory
of a simulation where our agency is real
and consequential yes yes Chris love it
you too and the last question yeah what
is the most beautiful thing in the world
overcoming
tell us more
I don't know I mean there's like a
thousand the Hollywood scripts over
coming to rise like the Phoenix from the
ashes yeah of your demise to rise above
yeah Ron's got it yeah I mean I don't
know what's more to say it's just that I
think at various points in history
whether we're talking about human
history biological history or one's own
personal trajectory you get really low
and hopeless and there's something in
that you know with the abyss staring
back or whatever where someone chooses
to press on and against those odds
you know the strings start and this
Symphony starts to rise and then we've
actually done something we didn't think
we could do from total despair to just a
sense of beauty is the word yeah that
was the most beautiful way I think I've
ever heard anyone describe overcoming
and what's on the other side is the
greatest treasures of life the greatest
beauties of life and we need a stronger
social fabric to make it easier for
people to have these processes of
overcoming what's that beauty and
treasure yeah what a freakin
enlightening show Nick this was a total
joy thanks I'm so happy you had a good
time yeah we had a great time we learned
so much from you thank you thank you
thanks probably working collective
learning everyone we love you so much
thank you for tuning in
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on what we discussed
let's get the community going the
conversation going also check out the
links below to public editor to goodly
laughs the tag works go and check out
all the links below follow public editor
on Twitter as well and join join the
conversation with organizations that
propel collective learning with artists
and entrepreneurs that are pushing the
edge of knowledge join them support
their efforts support them support us
let's go let's keep building everyone
and thanks to
Vargas are producing and directing thank
you again for tuning in and go and build
the future everyone go and manifest your
destiny into the world we love you so
much and we will see you soon
[Applause]
[Music]